Our plan is simple.
We can stop the spread by staying at home and reducing contact.
All across the country, stores are emptying and so are the streets,...
...as New Zealand gets ready for the lockdown.
Non-essential businesses in New Zealand must now close:...
...all bars, restaurants, cafes, cinemas, pools, playgrounds.
Were we overreacting?
Some people said we were,...
...and certainly when the scientists say shut the borders and lock down the country.
That's quite a hard scenario to justify.
A really core part of our success in this...
...was the coherence and comprehensiveness of our communication campaign.
I'm speaking directly to all New Zealanders today...
...to give you much certainty and clarity as we can as we fight COVID-19.
It was really important to have very clear and consistent messaging.
And so, while the job is not done,...
...there's no denying this is a milestone.
So, can I finish with a very simple, "Thank you, New Zealand."